l'automne 20-20 manque de couleurs pour
ceux qui attendent une chirurgie de la
cataracte
comme thomas pages elle un père de
famille de 56 ans qui travaille dans
l'industrie aéronautique
je travaille beaucoup avec leurs
ordinateurs j'ai besoin aussi de faire
l'inspection des morceaux moteurs
d'avions des partis fondateurs va bien
il peut encore travailler mais sa vision
est de plus en plus voilé
il est sur la liste d'attentes depuis un
an et se préparait à être opéré au
printemps
récemment bien on ne fait des démarches
pour avoir une idée combien de temps
encore on devrait attendre puisque note
que sa condition se dégrade donc on
s'est fait dire bsi encore vu beaucoup
de délais d'attentes lors du grand
délestage de du printemps nous passions
ont été les premiers à perdre et ne pas
se faire opérer pendant quatre cinq mois
on n'a pas opéré du tout presque nulle
part au québec le ministère de la santé
reconnaît qu'il y a un nombre record de
patients en attente d'une chirurgie de
la cataracte
au total 23 1706 personnes dont 9229
depuis plus de six mois comparativement
à 1391 l'an dernier dans les
établissements montréalais
ceux qui attendent depuis plus de six
mois sont passés de 346 l'an dernier à
3353 cette année les motards de plan de
charge des patients sont actuellement
dépassent les normes acceptables
tena pas plus stressant que perdre la
vie progressivement détaché sur la
qualité des deux villes d intéressant au
niveau des yeux est énorme la mobilité
la permis de conduire le travail c'est
sérieux pour accélérer les choses
l'hôpital de lachine finalement négocié
une entente avec une clinique privée
c'est du public mais on loue l'espace au
privé pour permettre de faire les cas du
public
dans le privé le ministère encourage ces
ententes spéciales qui sont négociés à
la pièce mais qui ne permettront pas de
tout régler
alors qu'on devrait être à 120% 125 % du
volume preco vite pour rattraper le
retard
on essaye juste de dire que nos patients
souffrent et qu'ils ont droit à des
opérations dans un délai raisonnable
après plus d'un an d'attenté
denise lavoie a été opéré à l'oeil droit
lundi c'est comme s'ils avaient une
fenêtre s'ouvre elle avant j'avais un
cristal est qu'ils étaient tous barbus
gilles on va dire au bac
je l'avais tel aviv est là de conduire à
nouveau et surtout de lire et d'écrire
je suis dépendant totalement protégé une
femme aidée par d'englos j'ai enseigné
toute ma vie ce sera après
l'intervention à l'autre oeil et en
remplacement de la hanche qu'elle attend
depuis un an
ici à nourrice despatie radio canada
montréal